hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was uh played in a
simultaneous exhibition held by uh the
the current champion of of that time it
was played in 1925 in Moscow and the
champion of course is Jose Raul
capablanca uh this was during the Moscow
Tournament of 1925 and on arrested day
of that tournament
simultaneous exhibition a 30 player
simultaneous exhibition was held uh in
his honor basically but also to test the
the strength of the Soviet players as as
it was formed a very very young Soviet
players now regarding the tournament of
the 1925 in Moscow it was a really a
spectacular event I did not cover it
during The capablanca Saga because my
sagas are basically organized to the
point where a player becomes world
champion in their the The Saga ends or
in the case of Paul Murphy you know when
he defeats uh Adolf Anderson but this is
a great tournament and I I do hope to
cover it in its entirety at some point
but um uh what I wanted to show you
these are the final standings of the
tournament so it was consisted of 11
International stars and 10 Soviet
Masters and the tournament Was Won even
though it was uh uh for example a
current world champion Jose rule
capablanca played former world champion
Emmanuel Alaska played but none of them
have won the tournament but actually as
sorry about that those are the the wrong
standings
uh I don't know why that happens yeah uh
sorry about that
there we go
uh but the tournament was actually won
by a Soviet player uh by the name of
effing bogalubo who I'm sure does not
um uh come come as a surprise to you you
can see that the volume of uh
representing Soviet Union won the
tournament with 15 and a half uh a full
point and ahead of Emmanuel Lasker in
second place and uh capablanca was also
half a point behind Emmanuel asker so as
you can see all of the names here it was
an incredibly strong tournament Frank
Marshall sadly tartar Carlos
romanovski and Greenfield uh Alexander
Lynn janevsky Federer
Boris verlinski Rudolph
Rubenstein if Akiva Rubinstein got 14th
Place then you know the the tournament
was very impressive and so on and so on
some I don't know well-known names like
Freddie 8 Friedrich samish um so very
very strong tournament but the game I'm
going to show you is not from that
tournament it's actually from uh
simultaneous exhibition that took place
on a rest day and the capablanca faces a
very strong unknown player now I'm sure
you guys are wondering if he's playing
an unknown player we don't know who it
is how come you're not wearing a hoodie
that's a very good question and we are
going to address that but after we check
out the game so let's see this and uh
who is this very strong unknown player
so capablanca has the white pieces and
he opens with D4 the very strong unknown
player replies with the D5 we have C4 E6
and not Knight the C3 so a standard
Queen's gamma declined Knight to F6 with
Bishop to G5 going for the modern
variation and Knight B to D7 the
so-called Knight defense against the
Queen's Gambit we have Ponte E3 and now
Bishop to B4 uh this is the Manhattan
variation uh probably named that after
the Manhattan chess club uh you know it
held some very very strong tournaments
capablanca played their last score
played there so pretty much everyone
played there it's like it's the it was
the second most most oldest chess club
in the United States and then at some
point it became the oldest uh chess club
in the United States because the oldest
chess club actually closed but I don't
think it's active anymore I think it
closed around the year 2000. so if any
of you are older uh you might have even
played in The Manhattan chess club so
yeah good for you it's a very nice piece
of History right there so here see
characters on D5 e captures and now
standard weighted three this is the
bishop to D3 or Knight to F3 or queen to
C2 but capablanca wanted to surprise his
young opponent and he played Queen to B3
this is a very very rare line and there
are only a handful of games
ever played with with this move uh so
let's see how uh capablanca's young
adversary reacts to this he plays Pawn
to C5 which is very nice it's a movie
you always want to play attack White
Center and for the moment you defend
your Bishop so capablanca takes it the
characters on C5 and now Queen to A5
putting pressure on this diagonal
there's always time to recapture on C5
and now how can a capablanca play this
if he goes A3 which he knows that he
should then after Bishop captures Queen
captures and our mystery person trades
uh what do you play let's say H6 you're
gonna trade on F6 it's not much okay
you're up a pawn but you have a double C
Pawn Doubleday Pawn nah nah not
something you can push to to Advantage
so capablanca tried Bishop captures on
F6 Knight captures and now he castles
Queen side he goes he goes all in here
and this is a very very bold move uh he
probably thought that okay my opponent
will make some slight mistake somewhere
and I'm gonna take advantage of this and
eventually win the game so let's see
what happened here a mystery uh person
plays castles and also it was now as of
move 10 that this position has never
been repeated again uh since this game
in 1925. we have Knight to F3 capablanca
continues development and now Bishop to
E6 and you can see how capablanca's
position is a complete mess
you can't really do anything I mean at
some point uh the Rooks are coming to
the C file the D4 Pawn will be pushed
how are you how are you playing this
capablanca plays Knight D4 he stops the
d-pawn puts pressure on the bishop here
and says all right try to take advantage
of this but still of course not
capturing on C5 Rook 8 to C8 it's time
to mount pressure along the C file and
uh you can just leave that C file
unattended Kappa Blanca plays C6 he
gives up he gives back the pawn in order
to close the C file but first Bishop
captures on C3 another problem is if
Queen captures which of course you could
play and it was played in the game game
then the the A2 phone hangs but the
problem is if B captures on C3 then B
captures on C6 and again uh Kappa
Blanca's position is a complete mess the
C5 can be played if the queen moves you
can capture an A2 the Rooks can also
just double up on the B file the Knight
is coming to E4 so it's a position that
basically plays itself so he has to go
for Queen captures on C3 and hope for
the best we have Queen captures on A2
and now Bishop to D3 okay you have to
recapture beat captures on C6 and now
King to C2 you could also try Pawn to F3
or some other moves but
uh it's it's never Pleasant uh if King
the D2 then you allow Knight the E4 to
come with the check so he played King to
C2 and now Pawn to C5 of course you want
to open up the C file as soon as
possible Knight captures on E6 and here
probably a couple Blanca thought that
okay now now I'm just gonna equalize
then okay maybe he gets a draw but it
should be fine uh because if he takes
the Knight then you have Rook to A1 this
traps The Black Queen on A2 so D4 is
forced D4 and now Rook captures an A2 D
captures on C3 B captures and the the
game continues equal material so not
much is happening here however his young
opponent played Queen to A4 with check
and now it's much much different uh you
can't really start running a wave King
to D2 then you recapture and now if you
continue running let's say King to A2
there's Queen to G4 with check and now
G2 Falls is play King to F1 to guard G2
then The Rook on D1 Falls uh none of the
moves are are sufficient here so after
Queen a for check B3 is played with now
Queen to a to check Queen to B2 and now
Queen captures and B2 capablanca
recaptures and only now F cap percent E6
and okay this is the position capablanca
is down a pawn but okay he should be
able to play an end game down upon
against uh an unknown 14 year old player
so uh you know it's it's not it's not
terrible F3 controls the Knight also uh
grabs more space in the center now you
have very nice control here Rook the C7
preparing to bring the other Rook into
the game we have Rook the A1 and now we
have Pawn to C4 no hesitation there b
captures and C for D captures attacks
the bishop and the bishop the C2 we have
rooked the B8 with check uh you could
also just play Knight to D5 but uh
there's time for that with King to C1
and now Knight to D5 putting pressure on
the E3 Pawn Rook the E1 and now Pawn the
C3 uh grabbing uh more space here now
controlling B to controlling D2 now Rook
to B2 is coming Knight the B4 is coming
how can Kappa Blanca defend this he
plays Rook to A3 it's sort of a tricky
trap if uh if his young opponent doesn't
really pay attention if he continues
with Rook to B2 then he can play Rook
captures on C3 and remove the defender
of The Rook uh so uh that would be that
would be very good for him but his young
opponent plays Knight to B4 he is not
easily tricked uh Rook to EQ and now
comes Rook to d8 playing every move
pretty much uh pretty much every move is
an engine move from black uh we have
Ponta E4 now the problem is if you play
Rook to A4 and go for the Knight Rook to
D2 is Just Deadly and now for example
Rook capture C captures with check now
the bishop will hang King captures will
captures on C2 and doesn't really matter
uh King to D1 Rook B2 defense the Knight
and if you if you harass The Rook the
Knight to D3 check defends the rook and
you're just gonna be up a piece so after
Rook to d8 E4 was played
uh it's up to Black to prove that he can
win this and now not the immediate Rook
to D2 because now if you go Rook to D2
it's a bit different now there's Rook
captures on C uh three and the rook and
C7 is now hanging so you have to play
Rook captures I need two Rook captures
on C7 real captures on G2 uh and okay
you have constant pressure here black is
better but it's unclear if you can
actually win this so here Rook the C6
was played and now what can Kappa Blanca
play uh probably best is just uh to
accept that uh he's much worse here and
play Rook captures on A7 and hope for
the best and then let's say Rook comes
to D2 you have to trade captures
captures you play King D1 will captures
on C2 and you know it's lost but uh it's
actually the best the best you have like
being this lost is is the best that you
can afford however capablanca does not
want this he played Rook to E3 and now
Rook to D2 uh we have Rook a captures
and C3 and now feel free to pause the
video and try to find the pretty much
the only winning move for black while
give you a couple of seconds
foreign
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting this uh uh
well a tricky move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
the simple Rook captures on C2 with
check this uh wins wins a piece here
Kappa Blanca recaptured and after Rook
captures on C2 check it was in this
position on move 32 that Jose Raul
capablanca resigned the game and are
very strong unknown player the 14 year
old uh achieved a brilliant brilliant
Victory against the reigning world
champion Jose roll capablanca so
incredible a fit in itself uh he resigns
as he's done material he's done a done a
full piece and of course there there's
no playing that it would be borderline
disrespectful to continue playing this
even if you are facing an unknown 14
year old player but then after the the
tournament uh there's a story okay there
are three stories here one is that
capablanca was uh sort of angry and he
just tipped over the king and left uh
the other one is that he you know uh
just through all of the pieces over the
board he he just snugged them down and
resigned that way and there's the third
one that I prefer as you know I always
consider capablanca to be a great
gentleman that as he was leaving Moscow
when he was on the train he asked the
tournament director who was the uh the
14 year old player that played such a
brilliant end game against him that you
know just completely crushed and didn't
leave him a chance and he said oh that's
our that's our very own uh Master he's
pretty strong for a 14 year old he only
learned just like two years ago but he's
making great progress his name is
Mikhail botv Nick so yes there you have
it that's why I was not wearing a hoodie
uh let me just improve this a little bit
there we go uh so capablanca's opponent
for this game was uh none other than the
future world champion mikhailboat
Finnick and he absolutely obliterated
the the reigning world champion Jose
roll capablanca so he was the the
basically the first real product of the
Soviet chess school and you can see the
they did quite a fine job uh you know a
dating him and already at the age of 14
he played such merciless chess and
capablanca there were no real mistakes
this game like he played Queen to B3
which uh it kind of makes the game
tricky and gives up the the starting and
that Advantage white has but still I
mean okay we have an equal position
against capablanca but between just
punished that uh mercilessly uh so yeah
I really hope you you enjoyed that and I
don't want to tell you from from the
start that it was between because then
you'd have high expectations this way if
kabalanka was playing an unknown player
which he was to him Copa Blanca had no
idea who he was and he was basically a
nobody uh the Soviet Union was just
training so so many chess players they
wanted to to create a very very strong
chess players and uh after defeating
capablanca in this simultaneous
exhibition he was he was really a star
he was starring his school he was
starring his chess club and I think it
it really propelled his chess career as
I I think also one of the reasons why
maybe he got more chances than the other
players and so on and so on one so I do
between Saga we're gonna know more but I
thought this was a nice story for you
guys to enjoy and share it with your
friends at the bar in the library
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of extra info info hope you guys
enjoyed that and I am definitely hoping
to cover uh the 1925 Moscow tournament
as it was in an incredible event so uh
hopefully I'll I'll get to that I would
like to thank you young Ned Riley BB
chess London system and kavaholic Madi
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing uh to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day